[Music]
yeah babel's uh company where are you
silence
silence
i had a dream about cat we should just
open up with that right away
listen it was ryan listen hold on hold
yeah
on
love cat
cat was somehow i think you might have
been in ukraine i can't remember
you were somehow naked and everybody was
going
and you were very beautiful and and i
had to be your shield but somehow i was
not wearing a shirt so i had to be your
protector so i was like guys everybody
calm down oh and then i had to hold you
against my body in my mind i'm like and
everybody's like how's that feel you
[ __ ] and i'm like god damn it and i it's
so soft yeah i know it was getting
soaked in my mind i was like well that's
very soft that's very female and then
with the mob going he's rubbing his
blood
no no then i woke up but i saved you
from a mob of people going because you
were naked and you were sitting on a
couch and you got up
and um
and and and and somebody said something
like this is dangerous you know because
and then you woke up she's very she's
young and very pretty
i think i saved her in ukraine it was in
ukraine yeah i think i saved you from
from some [ __ ] going on now what were
you watching before you went to sleep
there were probably a bunch of chitchat
special there
you're on catsuite am i right is that
what you're doing oh i can't read the
ukraine news at the same time was i
awake yes but let me finish yes
yeah no
i was not on your own my fans i did not
think this was gonna kick off this way
if you haven't actual thoughts about our
friend cattle i gotta share that well
thank you for saving me in your journey
you're welcome i appreciate it welcome
christian are you is there anything
worse than dreams
hypothetical
i've been having like i i yeah don't
tell me about your dreams because i'm
already i'm already bored yeah but i've
been having very vivid complete stories
yeah i came to where you can fully
remember it yeah do you remember your
dreams i mean i i never ever there's a
whole thing where you interpret your
dreams
a lot of psychology not that i'm not not
that i can like yeah fully think of i
couldn't like nicely
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm like
good i just never remember do you know
what they think you know you see
somebody who's crazy on the street like
the homeless guy talking about this and
stuff or they think
no they think that they think that
people like that can't dream they can't
sleep they can't get into deep sleep so
what happens is they're in constant
dream state okay
they're in rem
yeah so that's why they're hallucinating
so they're seeing [ __ ] and they're
talking and they're asleep they're
[ __ ] asleep yeah they're trying to
figure out a way to put their brains to
sleep so that they can actually start
sleeping because if you didn't sleep oh
my god
give me five days if you went five days
you'd go crazy you
know you you know you really do go crazy
yeah we talked about this there's a
certain amount of days without sleep
yeah you die without sleep before you
die without well your brain your brain
starts three days old with plaque you
have three days no water chin how many
days can you go without sleep before
you can go 24 hours without watering
well that one kid didn't sleep he's a
gamer it was just drinking energy drinks
and then he like worked i think three
days 72 hours straight and he died yeah
yeah they said no sleep but you know
what eleven dollars
but still i mean not everybody could
probably handle 11 days yeah you're you
know what i mean yeah you can't normal
research subjects uh eight to ten days
wow i thought it was less than that wow
i mean ten days that's that's crazy
that's a long you know what they can do
with you though you know what they can
what's really easy right they can if you
want to torture somebody yeah that's
what you remember
keep them up for two days yeah yeah
that's what our boys did with the old
isis and uh that's right
they blast like death metal oh no they
just keep waking you up they wake you up
every hour
they wake you up everybody definitely
you're not gonna fall asleep you can't
they're playing as loud as possible
isn't it part of some of the um
some of the military training
they'll just wake you up
like yeah navy seals there they don't
get much sleep turned yeah at all and
they purposely do it so your brain's
slower
you're you know yeah it's a good way to
break people down to see who breaks who
breaks
your body bless you god you ever stay to
sleep for 24 hours have i ever stayed
asleep no no no no i'm saying not got
any sleep for 24 hours i didn't in
college it was at night
i thought i was going to die nightmare
we didn't like it it's insane but hey
everybody stay up and drink energy dude
your body's just calm
you've never felt worse well in when i
went to afghanistan uh i i slept
less than i've ever slept okay i think
my adrenaline was why did you just like
kind of like in the military in a war
zone you're waking up in weird times
your clocks off i was working out i was
trying to it was just weird i don't have
too many struggles sleeping
pretty much very rare yeah
i'm pretty much called out yeah i
this past year and a half uh
anxiety i might have woken up every day
oh no that's fine i might have not slept
through the night ooh once yeah that'll
happen no i don't understand stress on
the anxiety of really focused i'll wake
up before exactly and i and i'm i'm
that's why i get good sleep i don't
stress about much good for you the old
brain starts up starts out can't get an
inaudible there's nothing healthier than
good sleep
there's no supplements nothing sunshine
sunshine a little vitamin d on you
you're an athlete daddy's feet that is
ankles that is daddy's uh calves you're
somehow still jacked up man
are you wearing the insoles and all the
shoes yeah those aren't great for it you
have the insoles in those maybe i don't
tight though right dude you got to stay
on it like yeah it's your job
it's never going to go away if you keep
just kind of doing it kind of right you
have to stay on it so be otherwise no
flaps my calves everything right
everything no flat surfaces can't get
out of bed and walk on wood flooring and
that's how you cure yourself yep it goes
away
yeah you have to be just apply it you
gotta you got this yeah unless you wanna
just live like this no i'm gonna go get
some orthopedics i'm gonna go get
professional orthopedics you'll get the
old man shoes
yeah i don't know though there's two
different philosophies i've been looking
at one is your feet have to splay out
naturally and then others is you know
that i mean maybe in the long haul doing
that
i'm telling you i met with the smartest
foot experts in the world not one of
them said walk on not one but not one
ever
i'm telling you it's not and yeah you
keep doing it
i do wow you're trying to do the
barefoot there
that's what i'm saying you keep doing it
well
it doesn't make sense i feel like you've
got to tell your footsteps
but you're not like that
you're 50 whatever years old 55 30 years
old
daddy's daddy's dying from the feet down
down around oh feet up yeah feet up the
feet over just [ __ ] how was uh we're
in louisville louisville is a great town
louisville a lot of cool stuff removal i
mean i i i had something from now um no
no
cincinnati but i met i'm
from cincinnati but i met you in
lexington kentucky so yeah some reason i
thought you're from louisville i've had
born and raised ohio baby all right
louisville's got louisville's got like
there's an under tapestry you understand
louisville's got some dark corners like
a little bit like they're about new
orleans so you can you can be walking
down the street yeah and all of a sudden
somebody opens the door and goes come on
in here you want to try this out
and all of a sudden they're there they
don't do all that
shoots out of their [ __ ] out of their
jeans though oops don't worry about that
come on
in here they're shaving their horns down
that you can get yourself into some
trouble in louisville that's where uh
that's why i turned in college oh sure
that's
you went to louisville yeah that's why
that's right and that's where the first
time ever got on stage was in louisville
kentucky really mm-hmm but you were you
the caravan where'd you go caravan what
comedy club oh yeah comedy caravan yeah
yeah yep wow i've done that i don't i
don't think it's there i don't i'm not
sure if it's there
this new club is amazing it's going to
be sick
it's downtown right guys who have tacoma
yeah they're great all that they do an
amazing job yeah it's just i was the
second weekend there i was the second
weekend i called my age
don't miss though boys these are the
same yeah put me at the everett theater
and i don't know dude i don't think it's
going well in everett they do not well
that guy has the biggest hit right yeah
yeah the caravan now not so much yeah
that's yeah that's the caravan but
what's the club you did brian it's
called the little comedy club brian uh
it's right in uh downtown louisville yes
sir right yeah you've been back those
streets those streets get a little
tricky have you been back there since
chevelle i haven't been back to
louisville
i feel like you did good there that's
your old stomping ground i haven't been
back to louisville i think since like
2012 maybe yeah well when i was there i
got came out to do my show
i came out of dinner and i was walking
across the street and i heard
yeah it's great i'm telling you it's
great but you are right you could take a
you could take a
you know wrong turn yes you can live in
downtown but in a good way not in a bad
way in in a new orleans way new orleans
what are you talking about new orleans
you off bourbon they're like hey dude i
don't
know
he'll die no you you'll get killed wait
what do you mean it's it's a hoodie it's
super dangerous but there's a there's an
underground like once you get outside of
it you don't oh no louisville's not like
that there's an underground though
there's an underground great i'm a good
looking guy
there's an underground there though that
i'm just saying there could be some
there can be some debauchery that goes
on there's a lot of bourbon that swells
yeah that flows yeah we used to get like
that the bars closed at four in
louisville we used to get so [ __ ]
drunk
yeah bruh and i would stay up that late
too all right yeah i i never understood
after our partnership
will you two miss my birthday party so
that's cool let's take a little break
from chatting with our friend chappelle
lacy b
dude when the moment arrives you're with
your girl or your man whatever it is
yeah you need to be ready to be just
ready dude you said it roman reich get
out you're roman roman ready
whether you've been in a relationship
for years or just getting started having
the confidence that comes from
preparation means you're free to enjoy
the moment when the moment is there when
intimacy comes it comes it gets to be
revelation
here yeah
right that's right get your wiener right
and look e.d erectile dysfunction very
common very common 52 percent of guys
aged between 40 and 70 experience some
form of erectile dysfunction not young
you want the wiener work go to get
roman.com fighter now to speak to a u.s
licensed healthcare professional about
your ed and get 15 off your first month
of treatment all right like we told you
52 of dudes between the ages of 40 and
70 will experience some form of ed and a
us licensed health care professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan event medication is
appropriate it ships to you free within
two
day shipping the whole process is
straightforward convenient it's discreet
nobody has to know you're stepping up
your wiener game all right that's right
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com fighter complete an online
visit take care of your edie without
even leaving your crib complete an
online visit today to connect with a u.s
licensed health care professional and
take care of it that's right go to
getroman.com fighter today if you're
prescribed you get 15 bucks off your
first month of ed treatment make sure
you're ready to have confidence in
control this fall roman ready roman
ready wiener oh yeah
listen guys
what happened brian if you want to laugh
if you want to laugh
you come to miami or you go to chicago
to watch you sure oh you want to see now
if you want the best insurance if you
want to find the best insurance because
insurance rates are jacking up these
days lucky for us our friends at the
zebra are here to help they make it so
easy to save hundreds on car and home
insurance in minutes well they compare
car and home quotes from every major
insurance company side by side giving
you all the facts you need to make the
right decision and they can save you
they save people an average of nine
hundred twenty two dollars a year on car
and home insurance combined that's
insane old man
just five minutes save time and money in
minutes show your support for the fire
and the kid by going to this
the zebra.com slash fighter and get your
free quote today that's the zebra dot
com slash fighter i forgot yeah on your
birthday no i i talked to him you well
you and my dad both that's fine
i talked to him yep we text each other i
appreciate it chappelle thank you for
that friday it was friday is my birthday
hey
don't say it it's what you're gonna say
what you gonna say what are you gonna
say what did you say
happy birthday nope not a hello it makes
me but look at how sincere my face hold
on
happy birthday nope
not working
you and my dad forgot
oh give him that birthday hug there you
go that's what you need yeah it's all
sobbing man you don't have birthday love
that
laughter at that
you're 39 39
last year
of the 30s there's new 40s new 30 i
heard though so i'm looking forward to
it as a guy who never thinks about the
past do you even remember 30. i mean
it's just been a
tailwind of this
30 up nine years of podcasting stand up
all this [ __ ] wait yeah you started yeah
started this at 30 yeah damn dude have i
known you that long
yep you know my entire 30s bubba god
damn
we're doing the goddamn thing
and you know him his entire 50s yeah and
40s yeah 40s maybe 40s you know me a
long time
um but you missed a hell of a b day
dinner we're our friend todd's house he
literally todd it's tony stark's house
it's the most insane house you've ever
seen mm-hmm his neighbors are like
trevor noah and elon musk
no talks
it's called a super agent yeah yeah yeah
todd's what's called the
like he's he's in those secret rooms
making deals i'm trying uh dalia was
there jeff dye delia's wife uh my
friends ryan and charlotte it's good
looking
hella harley cave good looking group
good looking group that was fun and they
they had some chef just making food in
the back bring it out chris goes i don't
know what this [ __ ] is but everything
tastes fantastic what kind of food was
it oh man the the main dish was like a
short rib you know because i don't eat
carbs it was like a short rib like
lettuce thing wow they had like some
cauliflower things all the breasts all
all very healthy but very good so good
man damn so good it was great was there
any wine any wine flow uh no they had an
open bar but you know i'm a whiskey
bourbon guy said a bunch of whiskey
bourbon everybody's sipping on you don't
drink wine at all
now no not not anymore yeah i can't
realize something you get yourself did
you get a little drunk on your birthday
at all i didn't feel like it how about
the fight companion you get a little
your little tips uh not really it was
such a good car this is the one where
it's like especially you know
dalia and jeff dyer you know experts
when it comes to hiding so i was like
we'll see how this goes you actually
know what chris brings the table but
just jeff has never done one but
especially for the jeff's first time and
you know chris not being a big fight fan
the fights were so entertaining yeah
that they were into it yeah like asking
great questions it was just one of the
best campaigns we've done that guy the
guy who fought volkanowski or no avocado
volkov yeah
[ __ ] he's got hands mm-hmm yeah wait a
minute
yeah yeah monster that was his hometown
what is it
what is his background he's a boxer
really
yeah but he looks his hands look great
did the goddamn thing yeah
yeah well you know what i have some
something to say about that one and then
i'm gonna make i'm gonna say something i
wanna hear you i can't wait for that and
then when uh arnold allen and dan hooker
were fighting it was like yeah round of
the year it was nutsos
and jeff goes where i come from
uh you get arrested if you hit a hooker
like that
so [ __ ] money
what are you about to say about patty
and i'll choose wisely because i love
that dude yeah i know you do and i know
a lot of people do uh-huh yeah i saw
something
i mean he got hit well he got hit
he got hit
and he got put on his back and he got
held there for way too long oh sure he
didn't get help
he's reversed he's got he's got some
he's got some liabilities there and and
it's
but here's the three but he's only 155
he's he's 155 so in his second fight
like i had anak on the shop show this
morning he was like man the kid has a
long ways to go like you know our in our
sport everyone's like oh i wanna see him
fight the top ten it's like
he's probably right not even the top
thirty so that's good then as long as
they they bring him up slowly oh i got
no problem yeah he's not but everybody's
talking about him being the next i'm
like hold on hold on no he has a lot
he's got here he checks a lot of boxes
the same way conor mcgregor did like he
has that okay factor and like the moment
can't get big enough for him but he's
got the advantage just has a ways to go
yeah he's got a crazy eye he's great
yeah yeah yeah that's fine but he's
entertaining he's a prostitute yeah yeah
okay entertaining he's getting sold on
o2 arena without the youth like he sold
huge venues before he moves in why is
that why is that just exciting has it
yeah people love it
the talent and the personality let's
bring them up slow like but everyone's
saying that yeah you can't listen to the
fans like no we want to see him versus
dominic cruz or whatever the [ __ ] it is
if he went to 55 or
you know we want to see him versus
justin gates he's like no no he's just
getting started thank you that's what i
mean yeah no let him let him do his
thing he's a yeah yeah i mean you
shouldn't be in the conversation right
now yeah it's nice but he just has a way
to go that's all i need to hear no one's
saying he's uh yeah i've been hearing
that
you know he's just getting started man
yep like they got that they fought and
clipped them but you know
yeah there's last fight too mm-hmm but
yeah he's always good that division is
just 55. it's a nightmare to get in the
top 20 is tough dude
i'm really excited about the other great
gilbert burns uh
we doing a fight companion for that uh
when when is that
april 9th yeah are you in town
i mean yeah because you have the tough
mudder that earlier you're doing it no
yeah of course we're not just have tough
mudder at 10. 10 a.m let's do a fight
companion that's the next fight company
here behind dude are you kidding me
right i think chris is out burns so be
you me and maybe jeff and one other guy
yeah
that's that's
now we're gonna see what comes that's
about
well i was watching a thing on him he
was he was in in practice he was
beating well competitions in tournaments
in sweden he beat a couple of
medalists olympic medalists and
wrestlers oh dude he's never lost over
his coach told me he's never lost a
round in practice well he goes with just
finn and the tv the tv's the
heavyweights
[Laughter]
against costas
like you guys haven't seen anything yet
like well i think what i i i think what
you're going to see is he's
versus the world i i just don't see
anybody
okay yeah i think that's a first round
finish for um oh that's not no shade on
gilbert burns he's an amazing fighter
but and then you're gonna see this that
guy's just on it you're gonna see it
let's run my prediction you can see
usman comes out and then you see cosmic
comes out go up to 185 and fight izzy
that's what i think it's gonna be he's
big enough yeah he's definitely bigger
yeah he walks around at 200 pounds he's
a big boy yeah i can't believe he makes
170.
i think what's going to happen if you
have hamza gilbert burns i think he
passed that test with flying colors and
then
he's just you know he wants to fight
he's a maniac he wants to fight non-stop
and you see he's like chill that's what
we do with stars but he's just different
animal yeah and i bet you get homs at
verse kobe kevin covington
that's it that's gonna be a long night
for kobe as great as your fight though
yep yeah yeah but yeah i think he takes
out gilbert and then it's colby and then
who knows what happens with that and
then he tries to go for oozeman
and uh god he's such a [ __ ] scared he
wouldn't go for husband right after
colby or he would have taken it doesn't
matter to him you could line him up i
bet they'd give him a title shot right
after he if he's just starches gilbert
to give him a title shot but
you know yeah
camaro and ed uh leon edwards are
fighting so yeah hanzo wants to be super
active
and he he doesn't care he'll fight
anybody al james certainly peter young
is going to be exciting i'm afraid
you're going to see it repeat but
beats him pretty
if hamzap beats gilbert without any
issues you could put uh
colby and hamza as the co-main event on
that just to build the phone that's
gonna be uh that's gonna be great
i just love watching colby just go bad
on people and then yeah could we talk
all the [ __ ] about yeah but you know
we'll see who knows that's what i would
do with him though don't make companies
he's already started talking [ __ ] about
him don't make contact angry i mean
i'm gangster i'm gangster my friends
brother i'm a gangster i'm gangster for
me i'm
was it him that you said he flew to
ireland yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a
monster
to go handle some business how about i
thought he's gonna have a drinking buddy
on the fight van jeff was so hung over
and he's been sick he's like i just
can't drink my like
it's the only reason you're here dude
i need a drinking butt chris doesn't
drink chin drank with me a little bit
but did you see that did he send you
that video of the guy
who opened for me forever no no you
didn't do a video of the guy who's who's
blind yeah that's that's my opener in
nashville
yeah
yeah i'll send the chin it's so funny
let's watch this this is it's instagram
so we should it's really inspiring it's
super inspiring like it's cool the
opener was blind yeah yeah so you know
this is really inspiring watch watch
this
super inspiring
[Music]
do i wear tight shirts now man
and the kid i'm the kid
the kid is very disciplined about the
way he eats now just so you guys know
it's basically
it's been two days dude i know it's true
you know what i can't do any more diet
for three months daddy can't daddy can't
drink red wine no do you come in here
every monday say this yeah and then i
slip
i know i like how brian always has
something he can't do anymore i know
yeah it's always something i still do it
though don't i yeah
cat you never thanked me for saving you
from the
ukrainian i did
right at the top of the show okay yeah
she did say thank you and i was just
there was dead air and i just wanted to
bring it back all right let's watch this
this is very inspiring
so not this guy the guy the guy the
doctor who comes in was my opener and
natural funny kid yeah i'm kyle thomas
he's a local nashville comic 36 years
old and i am a hundred percent
blind dr kaminsky told me that's him
right there yeah big kid can give me
back my eyesight you know and
i've got to give it a chance
i feel like these have been ready so
these have been a part of me for sure i
know
i know all right emotional here we go
all right
[Music]
says take a second look at him the
doctor's laughing
i need to push a button
do i push a button
when you see the there's these videos
when the little baby can hear from them
yeah
i start crying every time i thought that
was gonna be wrong too i was like you
look so scared i thought it was real i
thought it was like i can't believe you
thought well we should have figured it
out but he was wearing a freaking
he got me because i went i was like the
music and i go he's gonna be able to see
i can't take this i'm gonna start crying
too and he puts on the even when he had
the goggles i go those are [ __ ] weird
now my god
yeah jeff sent me goes dude super
inspirational
i clicked on it and i was like what is
happening
jeff is such a dick so funny gosh she's
so funny she's like
miami i'll see you this weekend this
video's so [ __ ]
what are you doing miami and prof
yeah naples tampa i mean just too much
florida you didn't do jacksonville
no jacksonville no jacksonville
yeah tough one what do you mean it's a
tough one comedy sounds jacksonville
yeah have you been there no there you go
i assume it's probably lit though don't
go there
go there
go to jacksonville yeah something
happened to y'all in jacksonville it's
just the bakersfield of florida oh don't
do that
i actually like jacksonville there's a
lot of pretty places but comedy-wise
it's tough brian you you seem to be
biting your tongue
but next time i'm in flies naples but
i'm all set on florida for a little bit
and i love florida crowds are great but
i went there so much in the pandemic
yeah it was all texas florida miami i
love i'm not mine
if you can't sell miami you've got
problems yeah yeah i'll be there this
weekend
saturday sunday yeah the gm he's gone
right yeah oh yeah justin yeah justin
yeah great he's great just nothing and
lisa right is it lisa i think so yeah
daddy's doing a sunday night doing
sundays i'd never do sundays because
you're doing a sunday night you're
finally kidding me yeah on monday you
don't get back to so we're gonna call my
age and i go what are you doing like
what's going on here and he just didn't
know uh
uh
who's the guest on wednesday mercy paul
jersey's coming remember paul he's great
yeah i love paul yeah great guy
new york i wish he could co-host on
monday
but he probably leaves sunday i don't
know when he leaves yeah wait what time
what time do you fly back from miami i
can't get more i tried to get back it's
such a good but don't do
sundays yeah why are you doing a sunday
it's probably yeah i mean who does
sunday nobody no
no no sunday that's the lord's day
but it's miami and i was like all right
i guess i don't know miami on a sunday
that's when everyone was just chilling i
mean
a lot of people so a lot of clubs
apparently on thursdays they've seen
across the board a drop
because they have to depend yeah after
the pandemic people just those are not
going out on thursdays it's really weird
it's like certain things happen you
can't put your finger on it so friday
saturday is when the clubs are making
their money oh yeah but that's in
general thursday or friday saturday no
matter pandemic or not yeah phoenix
though i [ __ ] thursday's thursday and
sundays thursdays in phoenix some
markets it doesn't matter like you know
stanford lives you guys are yeah because
you have a history with phoenix yeah
yeah you just and it just depends i just
don't work sunday it's the lord's day
you know it's the lord's day yeah it's
the sabbath
tis tis the south knew her to the
headlining game i don't do sundays no i
never you know well there was a time
when i used to do
when you first start you usually have to
do that's my day of giving thanks there
were times when you would do
i remember when i first started out
you'd do wednesday through sunday dude i
would get there on a [ __ ] wednesday
i'm sorry and then you'd be in like in
canada and certainly wednesday they'd
have a show wednesday thursday friday
that's aggressive i think jeff told me
yeah he did a tuesday through sunday
like last year just gone all week oh
that's vegas vegas will make you do i
literally i if that was the stand-up
game i couldn't do it well brad
garrett's club would do that they were
like they do it all week and i was like
i'm just kidding
unless you pay me
all the money in the world that's a lot
to commit to yeah no i can't a full week
like that
at the same venue thursday through
saturday's tough enough for me yeah you
can't do it yeah
i was thinking about how as comics we
live in
the truly a true capitalist world like
we are capitalists like if we don't put
bus in the seat and it's mostly up to us
then you don't have a job and like
nobody bails us out no pension plan no
boss it's just like it's all on us it's
all on us and oh by the way you better
keep coming out with new material yeah
and it's really an interesting thing a
lot of diy a lot of do yourself [ __ ]
yeah man daddy's playing the world right
back huh daddy was thinking on the plane
right back and i don't like those two
planes that's what breaks there's no
direct illusion that [ __ ] breaks me
louisville chicago and then chicago i
don't know it's just breaking but you
can find it
she usually directs there it's tough
dude i'm in chicago this weekend i'm
praying to god there's no snow that
traffic is so filthy i don't think
there'll be snow in chicago
this is the weather like up because they
have worse
you staying at the usual hotel that you
stand no no no no no only airbnbs oh
really yeah in chicago oh yeah
we're staying in a severe weather
outbreak
oh you're good oh that's are you kidding
me thank you
give me the 10 day chin give me the ten
days
35
so 35 44 showers that's not ideal friday
50
saturday 42 bring bring that means that
night it's gonna be chilly as [ __ ] go
ahead and bring yourself some
yeah that's chicago yeah you'll be all
right you're not gonna be in uh t-shirts
you gotta direct there yeah oh yeah that
depresses me that it's uh
it's cloudy in chicago
chicago
summer's great yeah it's still nice
uh yeah at least no no snow i'll take it
yeah the snow is what gets you to do you
know
coeur d'alene is remember that did you
go there when you went to tacoma i think
course
i told you about it dude that that i i'd
swam in that lake
god it was beautiful oh that's where we
stayed when we did
uh uh spokane or tacoma one of the clubs
i think it's an hour from
spokane no no
no it's too cold bro it was freezing
it was [ __ ] cold yeah that water's
nice
they hate when we talk about it because
they think it's like a secret but it's
definitely not corny i thought everybody
knew about it they get mad that because
the kardashians have go there on
vacation and all that [ __ ]
that's how it gets ruined it's so nice
beautiful i love coeur d'alene
i was doing a hype pandemic in quarter
so if you're in spokane mass central
locked down coeur d'alene nothing no i
had a pandemic nothing no idaho they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah it's so nice even
when we did boise boise
i've not been to boise oh my god well
man uh yeah montana's my i mean my fave
i don't know yeah yeah but montana idaho
in general like my fave boise montana
fantastic there's something amazing
about that i mean i go on vacation there
for a reason it's nothing
um but how about there were protesters
at my boys we did a theater in boise
there were anti-mass protesters i had to
go out there like hey
i'm with you guys yeah nobody's wearing
a master like really i'm like no like
move along
like went to another [ __ ] venue
that's [ __ ] what are you guys doing
you're scaring everybody yeah no
it's their choice they want their mask
on where no one's forcing anything
those crowds that was a different type
of energy yeah i'd like to go back there
yeah what was that theater called
i forget but it was all rock bands we
were the first comedy actor
it was all big bands remember oh the
green room was like this yeah it's a
[ __ ]
the green one was [ __ ] yeah the size
of a best buy really yeah it was huge
it's huge like everybody had like pretty
much their own room if they wanted to
that's cool how big is too big a house
like todd's house is that too big for me
my house is too big i'm talking my girl
about it it's like uh i like everyone be
on top of me yeah like i'd want one
level it's like too big there's rooms we
don't use yes yeah
that's that's the problem like it's so
interesting you can have this todd is
different his kid's older you know yeah
you know how old are his kids his kid he
has one son atticus is 10 or 11. okay so
he's older you know but yeah
but i'll give it to todd for as big as
his house is it's pretty homey it's
tough to make those big houses homie
yeah that's pretty homey oh really is
the way it's designed it's not like one
big open floor plan it's like sectional
and they weren't giving that house away
i don't think so otherwise i would have
tried to get it yeah yeah yeah they're
not going to give those houses oh daddy
cannot afford to live in that
neighborhood bel air excuse me sir yeah
no no no too rich for money what do you
want to downsize
yeah if i were to move houses i had
downsides for sure yeah that's too much
yeah
there's certain parts we don't use yeah
yeah i don't think i can do a big house
i freak out depends some people just
need more space i'm the same way i grew
up everything happens around the kitchen
anyway i don't know who needs that space
yeah my main focus would be the kitchen
yeah because you're always in there and
then you've got a whole squad
like some cheap about a dozen [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying i like your layout
of your house but how often do you use
the dining room you know no no no
holidays yeah
you know that's it
that's how i feel and i don't like
houses that are stacked one on like like
i like three story i know i like ranch
yes
no yeah cat were you in town this
weekend did you go somewhere you're
always a jet setter oh uh
stevie and i did a small road trip to uh
vegas because he had to go uh do he had
like a mailbox in vegas from when he
lived there and he had to return a key
you have to physically go there so the
key in no they had a weird policy where
you had to physically be there and sign
something so we went and did that i
played roulette lost twenty dollars
okay i was upset
i was up a hundred dollars and then they
had to switch dealers and this lady this
older asian lady was a hater and just
like swiped me out i knew anything more
than twenty dollars she was gonna take
me for everything i have asian
asian on asian crime we were at the uh
four seasons and then we went to the
mandalay department yeah it's nice
because they don't have like a casino
it's at the very quiet it's i think
top behind right behind mandela at the
very top of the strip so you don't
really get a lot of the like craziness
of
happening so that was really nice what
did you do chin
uh disneyland
again yeah well that's just there we
have season passes now you said it
sucked last time
yeah
it's got to be boring as [ __ ] no it's
awesome it's always awesome no chin
sneaks alcohol we drink yeah we sneak in
alcohol
but all the time everybody i know is
well because you don't have kids that
might be different but anybody with kids
like do not go right now like it's a
nightmare it's just so crowded so
christmas oh yeah spring break it's
still crowded so when you go to
disneyland
you go there and you ride the rides yeah
we bring our you know her my
girlfriend's nieces dude
buzz lightyear shooting game yeah it's a
bunch of stuff yeah cars rides yeah the
car rides fantastic why don't you just
drink while you're in the park because
they have alcoholic drinks only bear
though right yeah i think disneyland is
kind of tough but then california
adventure has wine kind of like beer and
wine what do you bring what kind of
alcohol we basically so if you ever want
to sneak alcohol in there they don't
check your like your little thermos you
know like these things that we have yeah
the thermos i guess what are they called
thermos
yeah they don't check what's inside yeah
so we just filled it to the top with
jameson and then we all just start
chugging taking shots who's you all
everyone with us
how many people me my girl her sister
our friends no we had like a group of
seven right yeah that's a lot of people
to be rolling with to disneyland that's
how you do you play bingo ever i know
you get all tipsy it's a little advanced
brian leave it below i can't ask [ __ ]
single questions you don't like just
going to disneyland you like design no
he's being an [ __ ] no
don't i don't need me to dig i would
have to be on all the blow
it's funny if you have kids i can't
imagine going as a girl we have we have
kids with us that's why oh yeah oh okay
now are the parents of the kids drinking
too or gotta have fun when you're there
you know sure
you're somewhere you're back in the car
like jesus christ
the the lines
oh
there's ways around if you do the vip
thing it's so expensive but still in
general this is such a were you there
for the entire day because i know some
people will go from the moment the park
opens to the moment it closes yeah
that's like my girlfriend
that's too much
about it i can understand where you feel
it's so cozy like you do feel like
you're always in another way
awesome you just you feel like you're
you're actually in like a disney movie
the music's there no it's so awesome
yeah yeah they have a starbucks there
what's your favorite shitty food italy
you know
how the tower of terror or no it's not
the guardian it's the galaxy
you never go over to uh california
adventures yeah we go back that's the
california adventure right yeah that's
the california adventure and then they
have the
incredibles ride
i think there's a yeah they took over uh
california screaming
hey was the uh pirates caribbean back up
it was always down when i was there i
did we didn't check it they because they
redid it because remember the pirates
were like something like hey baby they
got rid of they're like selling women at
one section and they decided to change
it oh that was lit dude and then they
also got rid of the splash mountain
because it's a historically a racist
story i guess what is it i was like it's
a [ __ ] and uh oh yeah yeah racist story
the splash mountain splash mountain
comes from a racist roots i guess so
they
why what is it i don't know if they've
taken it down or this song right there's
like the bear singing it's a soul
song that was connected to some sort of
that was like david right hashtag no
really how do people
i know
i told you that they well dude you find
racism the way a ghost hunter can find a
ghost bro they've got very they can do
whatever they want you make anything
especially for from old school story but
uh splashbound to remove song all right
if you remove the song you know i enjoy
it
i don't know the song as long as you
don't [ __ ] with the ride that's my
favorite ride yeah that's my favorite
fun ride it's great story fun time you
get a little wet a lot a big drop too
which is fun yep
deep water is a movie for the mean and
horny who's that beautiful girl i don't
know but that's hilarious
yeah but did you uh
do you see buzz lightyear doing a new
buzz lightyear movie and he uh
i thought it was because it was on the
news i think nine news or something it
was uh on ktla out here but
it was like oh uh there's some form in
the movie uh male kisses a male and i
was like okay that's strange for kids
why leave that in there but i guess the
female because another female
which makes it a little less right
when i don't know man the whole thing
i i just what bothers me in a way is
like
a black buzzer right here
all this [ __ ] is being pushed down my
[ __ ] fire dog
i have enough trouble explaining to my
kids how the world works in general can
can we just wait on that as it start i
don't know well the disney ceo bob bob
came out and like he listen if you own a
corporation as big as disney just don't
say anything but his thing is he said
something and then he apologized well
we're donating 10 million to lgb qt rs
or whatever and then that's not good
enough so then like all right well buzz
lightyear is going to kiss another guy
you know like that was never good look
here's the thing that was never disney's
mission disney was was providing
like essentially [ __ ] great stories
that had their roots in age-old story
okay so it's like a female character
hawthorne who is in a meaningful
relationship with another woman good guy
bad guy you know uh lessons moral
lessons in life all that [ __ ] okay boy
becomes man woman because a girl becomes
you know they cancel snow white because
she didn't uh consent to the kiss it's
unfucking believable if you
[ __ ]
right no look you're sleeping disney
should stick beauty disney should stick
to what made it so great and why people
go
everybody gay straight black white gets
taken
dude yeah if you guys want your gay
stories invent your own disney [ __ ]
come up with your own [ __ ] you know
make it a gay tarzan make it see how
that does well that was
but to them it's probably not as big
they wouldn't be as big as disney so
disney's probably to them they're like
hey they can put this out there for you
i don't know
i'm just like disneyland i'm just trying
to do it you should be like [ __ ] off you
know that's not our mission of course
our job isn't to make a good job yeah
and i don't really want you
indoctrinating my children in your in
your gender agenda in your in your gay
agenda and all your agenda but that's
also not their job no saying like so
don't make it your job right
why are you why is it what you're a
fictional character look your schools
are all going to be teaching equity
meaning it has nothing to do with what
your your competence it's it's there's
an equality of outcome we're going to
enforce enforce like in a lot of like um
places like abc and stuff they have this
new doctrine which says 50 no matter
what of our executive staff are going to
be women regardless of who's more
competent for the job okay we're going
to have a representation and you're
going to fill a box yeah three years
because then the it's going to go to the
should work yeah it's like who's the
person for the job man woman asian
people well there's probably like good
women out there it looks like they're
going to get no but here's the problem
so engineers
almost
almost overwhelmingly represented by men
why for whatever reason men are just
yeah they're just into things okay if
you'd say now engineers have to be 50
women 50 men
there are not enough women who are
natural engineers who want to go into
that business to fill those gaps so then
you're going to have to have jobs yeah
and good engineers so you're not going
to have good engineers if you do that
yeah yeah shitty female engineers who
are like all right yeah i can get a job
doing this because
it's like an easy thing to get yeah
scandinavia has the most has the most
equitable they they enforce equity and
what's really interesting is when you
make all things equal men and women
which who are different mentally and in
their interests men and women just
gravitate even more so you have way more
female nurses in scandinavia represented
than male numbers oh weird what a
surprise
because when you give people the freedom
men and women are very [ __ ] different
and anybody who's had kids with a woman
knows that correct yeah you know they
just know that some disney just stay out
of it dude
awesome but buzz lightyear is a [ __ ]
but this is basically this is an
inflexible minority that's very activist
and what you have to do is go well
that's cool you can go ahead and fight
for your marginalized group but don't
[ __ ] come in here and try to
indoctrinate my children i don't [ __ ]
agree with a lot of your jobs
do you think it would
have hurt disney if they didn't
you know add the buzz lightyear the way
they did it would be fine they would
just probably talking about it they
would probably just get an uproar online
but they're gonna they're gonna learn
they're gonna learn by by changing the
narrative to this
small fraction of society that the
parents like i don't give i don't they
can do i mean buzz lightyear could [ __ ]
another dude still take my son if they
blur it out you know what i'm saying or
cover his eyes yeah but
there's a majority of america i would
say the majority who aren't going to go
see this now because that narrative's in
there yeah because i don't i don't at
the end of the day disney is a company
so once it hurts their bottom line i bet
you won't see this again correct
guarantee you won't see this again
because the problem is anything woke
touch turns to [ __ ] yeah and and it's
not that i mean one thing that's gay
i want children who are naturally i want
them to feel i don't want them to feel
ostracized
and speak of this like i'm not looking
at you and assuming that you don't like
gay people no i don't but i feel like
you are though chappelle you know with
brian
you're you're that is not disney's job
and you're you're jumping into an area
where traditionally with the power of
disney had nothing to do with that [ __ ]
it had to do with teaching
like archetypes and old stories and
sometimes some people don't fit in all
the time okay well you come up with your
own ideas then you can't fit everybody
in yeah you can't it's not also not you
like i'm sorry you sent me that thing on
that on that um transgender switch yeah
so she's six four this person's six foot
four all right and i guess you can call
this person a woman but i'm i have a
different idea on it and and and you're
talking about six before they were four
hundred
she was four hundred and like fifty
seventh ranked male 1
and now and now with a straight face
with a straight face people are this is
a biological male a biological male with
all the advantages
bodies are not equal and now you're and
now you're interviewing this brave
quote-unquote woman for and and saying
you know you won the ncaas
no well like i i think it's also showing
your time
this is not a good swimmer so there's a
no just not it's not good it's not for
you yeah if you can't compete with the
mail it's not for you but then also wow
when they take the picture it shows
first place and place third place yeah
the second and third are literally like
they're off on their they're together
like staring at her yeah the second
place is the second third and fourth
place
is it on this channel you know it's
funny but i feel bad for a hardcore
feminist because they don't have a home
where republicans are too pro they're
pro-life so they don't have that and
then democrats now are pro-trans so
feminists are in the
in the wilderness now now they're like
roaming around the [ __ ] do i go yeah all
the work we've done for women and now
yeah you've got biological men coming in
but you know that's what changed the
rule so you got to be on hormone
replacement i think for five years
before you can come over before it was
two years yeah right that ain't fair so
they did five years now okay that's good
uh no no i still don't i don't think i
don't think biological males should be
in female sports but they should be able
to compete it's just not with with your
other born women
have a trans league it's what i said
about disney if you want that have it's
no problem but just have trans people to
compete against transformers worldwide
let me know how it goes let me know how
your trans movie does in china all good
brazil
the other show yeah that's a very very
tiny minority very tiny but they're very
loud on social media yeah this could be
a dumb question but she just became the
fastest swimmer for in women's history
do you think she kind of threw the race
maybe to like take some of the heat off
of her or no i don't know i don't watch
swimming well i don't think that you
know well we have asterix shout out to
the girl who beat her though you know we
have astrix yeah she's like yeah [ __ ]
we have asterisks for people who take a
lot of steroids and break all the there
should be an asterisk like this this
should be a record you think yeah
if you're not if you're not going to
allow barry bond to the hall of fame she
can't be in the record book yeah i agree
correct same thing it's cheating it's
more and listen i'm all pro trans pro
gay all that stuff yeah do your thing
you shouldn't you should not not not be
allowed to compete because you feel
trans do your thing you should be able
to be competing against normal
girls yeah yeah
imagine
anybody in here imagine that's your
daughter in second place she should have
been first man yeah she's second place
now yep now now try to be normal like
that and go on twitter let me know how
it goes for you you're gonna get eaten
alive on twitter yeah eating a life
that's crazy i i wanna i wanna oh if you
try to defend
if you try to try to work second place
really first you can get destroyed yeah
but also i wonder how many of those
people are real is that is that russian
trolls too or is that how many people
are actually a lot of them are a lot of
them are i think a lot of them are
because they're not they're the loudest
on social media i would love to hear
someone's like logic someone that's
defending it i would love to hear like
just someone's like like
help me understand because i because i
agree with what you're saying like it is
tough like they're posing in protest i
don't blame second third and fourth oh
if i'm saying place i'm telling my
daughter just keep saying your first
place yeah yeah i don't blame them for
that that's that's uh that is well look
look how look at what i was used to a
man dude look how much bigger
than the right it's so ridiculous it's
so insane what are we talking about yeah
so then c double a change the rules i
think it has to be four or five years of
hormone replacement therapy before you
know what i mean not good enough
but they didn't instate it for this
year's championships because it was two
last minute
what'd this guy say let me see this when
she was on the men's team she didn't win
anything very big like this there's no
chance of it whatsoever all right we
don't have to watch this um
it's been done to death but yeah but i
my thing is that the smaller minority
will keep hammering this until it's
normal and then you just have a bunch of
men
in women's sports and it would just
destroy women's sports and nobody wants
to talk about that well they are talking
about it but it's like
i i it seems like they would like i
don't know
like they would never pull this off for
like the nba
oh no no you know what i mean like if it
was the other way around if it was a
female
that
or even a male a male nba player
you'll see the first transracial stuff
go on
well if you can be trans if you can be
transgender yeah i'm gonna ask you a
question honestly so i identify as a
woman okay okay you're ugly sorry yeah
now
um
i now identify as a 30 year old i'm
being serious i identify as a 30 year
old black
woman okay you tell me why i can't
because you say it's okay for me to do
identify as a man as a woman
but i i now identify as much younger i
don't think that would fly you might
think i don't give a [ __ ] go ahead dude
but
what are you trying to do with it i'd
like benefits of some kind i'd like uh
like
i don't know i don't know if that will
fly government i'd like a government
loan i'd like a government loan i'd like
a low interest a lower interest loan
there's certain programs but let's say i
don't i don't think that let's say
you're 21 and you want to get into
school like ice okay i feel like uh i'm
a trans asian you know because asians
getting into why can't i do that why
tell me chappelle give me the logic
i'm just saying like i don't know when
it comes to race especially
if a white person was straight up like i
identify as black you know angry black
people i understand that oh i understand
they're also a lot of singular and a lot
of women that are angry that men are
saying that they're now female without
having anything
any estrogen treatment so yeah so what
is what you're trying to do with it i
don't care like if you came out tomorrow
i was like hey dude call me uh brianna
no but you you do but i don't i don't
think you share daughters
scholarship away that's right oh yeah
for sure
the problem is that we do care now now
the justification what i'm saying is the
logical justification
i identify and the way i personally
identify must be respected at all costs
and not only must be respected at all
costs society has to bend to my costs
that's my issue and then so you you
couldn't run a society that way because
now you're saying now now we we do have
we do have certain measures that people
take how many of them are genuine like
you know what i'm saying like there has
to be a way to actually check
check this because how how much of it is
there's no way to check it right now
because how much you say you are genuine
you know what i'm saying like if so
let's say i'm the
500th ranked heavyweight in the world
yep and i go you know what i actually
feel like a female
and then i go to female heavyweight
fighting yeah i'm the best of all time
just watching i don't know if i get i
don't know what white falls it sucks
because i don't know if i get that i
think that person genuinely probably
transition that maybe i don't care yeah
go ahead yeah yeah you can't compete
against regular women and that's what
i'm saying that's all it's unfair they
probably just yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah they're not saying that i
know and i think she should be allowed
to compete just do it with other
transgenders yeah yeah
genetic makeup yeah if you work at
google okay and you're really good at
your job and you're leah thomas and you
you just feel like a woman and you
transition and you're 6'4 it's fine and
you want me to call you a woman i'll
call you a woman all day i'll refer to
you as she i will never treat you any
and and if you're good at your job i'll
promote the [ __ ] out of you i don't care
if you're trans if you're a great
surgeon i want the best surgeon i don't
care you're good if you're [ __ ] if
she was really funny she'd be in with us
yep yeah and yeah like i don't put her
on stage i [ __ ] say i mean i don't
give a [ __ ] if you're funny i don't know
what right
if you're taking my daughter's
scholarship away though if there's
things like that where you have a
biological advantage and we know this
that's right that's why i dropped the
line it's it's crazy that like the the
coach doesn't say anything like oh no
the the team came out i think 14 out of
16 signatures and it was they were
unnamed we're like we do not support
this yeah no one does no one does no one
does just so why why is there still gold
people in higher education
like a couple of trans professors and uh
and and their allies who live not in the
real world and i i am very skeptical i
don't want to make the world a better
place they're just in they're just in it
to destroy they're trying to tear down
everything yeah
they did that's who it's the far left
sort of the talk about the oppressive
hierarch you know patriarchy and all
that just doesn't work they don't live
in the real world they just don't good
this is exhausting
what do you got jen sorry all right
that's be tough even for that
transgender swimmer like you know she's
like what they're going yeah she
because she's probably like let's say
she actually feels transgender she's
like well i want to compete i feel like
a female i can't compete with the mayor
but also what else there's no there's no
other division for me like i don't want
to not
that's what i'm trying to say as well to
be like that like that right there but
then transition after college yeah that
doesn't matter
then also transition after college yeah
this person this is what it takes to be
a collegiate athlete yeah there's
something going on with this person and
they know what they're doing
what would have happened if she stayed
uh like as a trans woman but then try to
compete with the men like she there's no
uproar there's no headlines why wouldn't
she just do that instead
because she's not she can't finish first
place she's the 435 ranked male and
collegiate because this person was a
terrible not not not a good swimmer i
mean i feel like i could basically rings
what 400 dude you give me two months
i'll be in the top 500. is it so this is
your career and your 500 400 whatever
you go you know what i suck at maybe you
just say yeah i can't compete as a male
i'm going to become a woman and i'm
going to come you want to be a woman
that's fine now you want to compete and
take all of their all the titles away
and all the glory and set the records
that's so suspect i think how long how
long when were they a man
two years ago three years ago they were
at penn
yeah
so a year of testosterone treatment or
whatever is this but even the team's
like dude we we support her and what
this yeah we just don't support her
competing against us on our team like
this isn't fair i guess there was a
transgender
uh woman in ukraine i think who wanted
to
go with the women
oh well no you know what happened at the
border at ukraine so if you're a man i
think under 60 you're not getting out
you're fighting the war yeah a
transgender
woman who used to be a man was like oh
we're out even though he had a dress on
and the ukrainian government
i don't even [ __ ] what you associate
with you're built like man pick up a
[ __ ] gun and fight for the country
they wouldn't let transgenders out yeah
they are [ __ ] right and more and more
time
we need bodies let's go they're like yes
sweet dress get a [ __ ] ak-47 what are
you doing what do you what what
that's what's that's what yeah yeah it's
dicey man it's it's so like
it's so different in other countries
yeah oh oh it's all the different ships
yeah all the difference
damn my favorite is the stiff neck turn
uh
yeah
different yeah dude very cool
that game needs you on the front line we
do here go go
go give uh putin your pronouns
there are plenty of ukrainian women
fighting by the way oh yeah
easy on the eyes yep some of them are
easy on you there's a beauty pageant
queen who uh actually is the country now
oh they're so funny hey how's your
pronouns going north korea or china
go give your pronouns in brazil no it
doesn't
although brazil has its own little
yeah it's not safe though it's not
yeah sure they have a hit squad for gays
and trans where they kill them that's
true they seek them out and kill them
that's the problem that's that's the
beginning you know it's not good that's
yeah that's not the same
that's why i'm like even though we're on
the extreme left here with that trans
stuff i'd rather have that where we're
arguing about this
swimming than a [ __ ] hit team yeah
that just specifically [ __ ] goes out
yeah i agree yeah that's great that's
part of america it's all good this is a
debate we're this is part of the
american experiment where does a trans
person fit in yeah they're they're then
and we just need more of them to create
their own leagues that's awesome and
also no one's trying to like rule that
person out as a person just like hey
we're trying to figure it out and julia
thomas is a flash point and and you have
people like me of my generation that
have a natural emotional visceral
reaction i'm not i'm not on board with
it i'm not going to apologize for that
it's the way i i just don't think it's
fair yeah there's a lot of things i have
an issue with but it's this just [ __ ]
conversation could be worse it could be
in russia could be much worse from
brazil isis throws gay people off robes
yes it's very frowned upon in iraq
middle east
you know it's frowned upon everywhere
but here probably yeah canada is good
yeah
ken's good with everything what else you
got jen b let's take a little break
because i want to give a shout out to
edmonds for sponsoring this episode of
fighter in the kitchen dude car shopping
is confusing it can be stressful yes
finding the right car right now very
inventory
dude i'm freaking out man you gotta make
the right choice you know who's gonna
help you our friends at edmonds they go
the extra mile to make sure your car
buying experience is easy all right and
it's honest all right
they have online shopping tools they
have the latest consumer advice they got
you covered man they have over 50 years
of trusted car shopping advice and price
guidelines all right all in one place
brian that's right and the current
cursors means that some models are
harder to find more expensive than usual
highlight the the and then that's the
the thing they highlight essentially or
they will highlight the cars that you
can afford they're really good at
finding things like that they do side by
side comparisons dude over 50 years of
trusted car shopping advice and price
guidance all in one place i've used them
a thousand times who has it on edmonds
they have unbiased research they got
reviews and industry expertise and it
helped employ employer car shoppers to
make the best decisions
they're making fun of my very straight
teeth that are soon to be straight if
you want to get straight about your car
buying edmonds edmunds.com
um
visit admins.com click on edmonds best
car rankings research and compare
vehicles that's edmonds
e-d-m-u-n-d-s dot com edmonds we drive
it like it is
they're too nice up there
i know we're tired of talking about this
but this is just a little update kanye
was yanked from the grammy's lineup this
year due to his online trevor noah had
the best tweet he goes yeah i said to
council cancel not cancelled
wait council not cancer yeah that's so
funny
that's a bummer too because he's such a
great performer hey but also you're lost
grammys
what is this
that's the game athletes actors
producers writers directors media figure
it out what does that mean i don't know
uh here we put time and time again they
show us that they only want to steal the
culture not allow you ever to be their
equals and more than obvious move for
reasons of minuscule actions the grammys
have that last minute decide to pull
kanye west from performing on the show
as if we didn't know it was coming could
be because trevor noah is hosting oh and
there was a conversation held amongst
his team in the academy that led to the
decision or because yi's account was
suspended just days ago for reasons i
know especially in a world where all the
negatives of the world can be found on
the same app with no repercussions or
suspensions
fair point we'll just say it's all of
the above and continuous disrespect for
us and all that we have brought to the
table of entertainment media sports over
the last hundred years especially speak
your mind in this country for yourself
family or people and you're ostriched
immediately
and if you push them hard enough they
will stop at no end to try and put an
end to you as a whole i for one have
never been scared to speak my mind even
understand the consequences may be i
can't sleep at night knowing i was quiet
about issues burning holes in my heart
or narratives incredibly push all right
i say this i'm just whoa
i'm woke and while i am let me remind
you like
where this right jump off the game train
let me remind you that colin kaepernick
still isn't allowed in the nfl there's
many reasons for that game he's not good
sir lynching just became a federal hate
crime in 2022 and you can now be
discriminated for employment because of
the way you decide to wear your hair
geez thank you messiah for life thank
you massa for allowing us to slowly
progress for allowing slowly progressed
as a race hundred years after
uh hella [ __ ] be a joke everywhere you
turn these days but let's keep playing
the game until
so somebody wakes us all up all right
there you go
um you know what's tough about that for
me reading that
these guys are [ __ ] millionaires
yeah
well but
like i understand there's an issue and
[ __ ] at the same time
that's part of the american debate too
right there
yeah yeah yeah
i mean it's just a guy it doesn't matter
what my point of view as a guy as a guy
with with four thousand dollar guitar
collection yes five thousand dollars
sorry five
it does become tough you know hearing
certain people just talking about like
certain issues when it's like bro you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and i'm not saying money [ __ ]
it's everything you know money doesn't
you know some people
have a lot of money and aren't happy you
know what i mean the only problem though
chappelle if the guys like the game and
kanye west don't speak out the the
people that don't have the money aren't
going to move the needle so you're like
their voice won't be heard sorry another
guy yeah and also it's like you there's
some things i agree with that post other
things i don't know colin kaepernick i
think such a bad point i don't know
i don't know
his football also he's bigger as the
kind of
no pun intended the black sheep of the
nfl you know and
because if they let him back in here let
me take that let me take this back
actually when i think about it yeah
please do the game yeah actually comes
from
you know the hood he probably he didn't
have anything growing up no that's
self-made self-made but also like i
think it was just that was an emotional
reaction from kaepernick's interesting
right because kaepernick kneels okay and
it's funny how americans and human
beings look at it differently depending
on where you are on the spectrum right
so kaepernick meals a lot of people go
you don't respect veterans
or you're disrespecting the flag that
people have died for that's what happens
over here then other people go well he's
protesting police brutality
i'm black or i have a lot of friends
that have gone through this something
needs to change that took balls because
he's going to pay a price for it so it's
just two different perspectives right
but some reason americans have so much
trouble being
against priests police brutality
and pro-veteran like it's really
sometimes i don't know americans have to
choose sides it's really weird yeah
there's a lot of people
and like i i don't get that emotional
about that because i go i i i do i do
agree with you i feel like there's so
much with this like choose a side of
something you know what i mean it's like
where it's like i can't what i can't
like something from over here and like
something from over here and also like
you know what i mean like you know they
just put you into a category yeah it's
like this put it into a box it's trying
to
stand
that makes sense but uh charlemagne says
it best he's like i don't like colin
kaepernick's trying to get in the nfl
like this league that doesn't want you
in it you're a bigger voice your story
your narratives bigger with you not the
get in the nfl then you know all right
now shut up you're in the nfl is he
still trying he says he is i think it's
a political move i think it's a pr move
yeah because you can go look i'm still
in shape i'm throwing the ball here and
most nfl like
scouts like we're good man and it's not
a black or white thing or racist thing
he's just not very good he like towards
the end of his career he just wasn't
good he wasn't that good no it was never
that good he was good when he first came
the league took the niners to a
championship but right he was never that
good he fell off they figured it out so
it's like why would he why would he
still why would he try charlemagne's
like but charlemagne said it best you
know he knows he's like i think it's a
pr stunt because he has he did an entire
uh documentary on netflix basically
comparing the nfl to slavery modern day
slavery they can then you can go work
for them yeah it doesn't make sense it's
weird
what's your take on deshaun watson being
brought in i think by drafted by the
cleveland browns
uh not don't say drafted right because
they're not drafted
he got traded there
uh you know 22 women came out they
couldn't file any federal case against
them there's no no there's nothing so
it's a civil case now because he touched
them some of them some of them he
touched wrong uh he would hire masseuses
offline and then you know walk in and be
butt naked with his penis out and i
think you for some of them supposedly
for some of them i didn't hear force i
heard he touched some of them
inappropriately i don't know
while they were massaging him or some
[ __ ]
but um
it's tough because if you're an nfl team
you know how good desean watson is no
amazing yeah dude what that's ridiculous
top five a monster monster very rare
human being then he's well he's so
[ __ ] good
so if you're the cleveland browns and
you want a good quarterback there's no
federal charges against them they
couldn't find it he said she said
so
let's say in a weird world
and you know i'm sure there's some
hanky-panky there there's something
going on there should he never work if
you look at this it's like yeah it's
like this one
so what's he said she said the the the
fbi the law enforcement looked at it
there's no federal case
you tell me should never be allowed to
work again right i don't think there's
no crimes here because there's no crimes
but also cleveland browns are worth you
know a billion dollars
decided to take the chance on
he's a very good player
now if he wasn't as good as he is would
this even be a conversation no he's so
far out did you see what he's saying he
kept trying to direct me toward his
penis when he was massaging me but
there's no specifics it just becomes
like it's like all right well here we go
and i have no doubt
went on but
bless you yeah i'm sure you did some of
that it's just when you look at the law
that is what are you going to do
what do you what are you going to do
with that you know should he never be
allowed to work again after this yeah
it's also that the people saying this
are anonymous so that you don't know how
to
yeah
as we're all a social media posts by
public publicity seeking plaintiff's
lawyer i recently became aware of this
lawsuit that has apparently been filed
yesterday i've not yet seen a complaint
but i know this i've never treated any
woman with anything other than
utmost respect the plaintiff's lawyer
claims that this isn't about money but
my forefathers made a baseless
six-figure settlement demand which i
quickly rejected unlike him this isn't
about money for me it's about clearing
my name looking forward to doing that
here's what is interesting
i now it makes him look guilty but if
you want the easiest route for this not
to get out you should have paid the
weight yes but because you can and then
there's a there is a be and this is the
other thing to keep in mind these women
are coming with a team and there's a
number to make it all go away they're
all represented by the same guy yes so
what happens is one guy sees a lot of
money all of them come together and he
says all you need to do is provide your
testimony and you'll make a lot of money
my guess is sometimes you're a masseuse
and they offered him the the settle and
he went nope i'm gonna fight this which
to me i'm like all right maybe there's
something that's that that i admire that
i know we all tend to be like oh he's
guilty but it's like all right maybe
there's something there and then here's
where it gets very dicey
the the lawyer it's just not any lawyer
the lawyer in houston the big boy yeah
now he lives two doors down from the
owner of the houston texans they're very
good friends deshawn watson wanted out
of houston now when he starts demanding
the trade now all this comes to light
how is very strange how interesting i
don't know how [ __ ] interesting
but don't you no real like notice though
in a federal
court they looked into this nothing and
they look deep and they look and for the
easiest thing to do for deshawn watson
you guys how this works he has all them
he sounded like a 400 million dollars oh
he's got money all the money he's dude
you're talking mvp candidates so [ __ ]
good dude wow amazing quarterback wow he
has the money maybe so it had been so
much easier for him
leave me alone and he's like [ __ ] off it
though that's where i kind of go he's a
boss what's going on yeah you're like i
admire that me too that's why i put a
little more trust in him where i'm like
well my anybody else like
even if i didn't do it you just go i
don't need this [ __ ] i'm trying to get
traded here give here well i've always
said though you know if you're gonna if
if you didn't do it say that voice it
like fight it well that's what he says
and sometimes everybody should know it's
really hard to fight sometimes you can
make it impossible you can't sue anybody
because it's gonna cost you more money
than you have and and also you're going
to lose that case and the reason you're
going to lose that case if somebody
brings accusations against you you can't
sue them because it's called the slap
act they are telling their story it's
its first amendment
so the judge will throw it out of court
and in california at least you have to
pay their legal fees so any time you
bring pretty much everywhere yeah so if
somebody says something about you and by
the way here's the other thing if you
say they're lying they can sue you for
definition that information okay i paid
their leaders yes now and and if they
they come up with a story whatever it
might be and you decide i'm gonna go
after you and good lawyers
yeah it'll cost you just to file that
it's gonna cost you 50 100 grand
it's gonna cost them 80 grand or
whatever now when when it gets denied by
the judge which
most likely is going to you have to pay
their legal fees too yeah and that's
five you want to how many how many
people do you want to sue then also if
you have a
lawsuit where you like most big-time
lawyers won't take the lawsuit on if
they don't think they can win
so they'll go towards whoever you're
suing go hey man here's the deal
we can keep doing this
or other just go away and this stops but
if you keep doing this
you're going to get my bill
and most people don't have that money
that's talking two three that's 100 500
grand yes and people have enough money
sometimes
where they can sue you or they can just
and they'll just keep it going and
you're like dude i can't keep up with
these lawyer fees you get those lawyer
fees dude
80 grand they come in chunks
it comes in chunks you're like how much
but it's only been a month that's 80 000
yeah yeah lawyers are being it's not fun
god damn what else you got yet
so in south carolina it is officially
legal and
available to
prisoners on death row to have a firing
squad it always made more sense to do
this
cheaper wait what not as barbaric as
like injecting just spill your heart out
everybody shoots in the same space the
same place right the heart
and you just did you know that only one
person uh only one person is has like an
actual bullet no no that's not true one
person everybody has bullets except for
one person
so nobody knows you don't know for sure
if you were the one who killed them oh
okay i got to reverse yeah because i
know i know they did it so
you could have somebody miss and it
would be bad because yeah
[Laughter]
am i out
so everybody has a bullet except for one
person so in your heart you don't know
you're not sure if you're you were the
one who okay
uh so this was back in june south
carolina halted the plan executions of
two men brad and freddie owens because
the inmates only had the electric chair
option that'd be my last [ __ ]
electric chair the state decided to
postpone their execution until they made
change to the broad river correctional
institution in colombia saying the
facility did not include the capacity to
perform firing squad executions
yeah i'd be so scared uh the fire the
uh will fire their weapons through from
the other side of court officials the
renovations cost the state 53 000
yeah apparently there was an issue with
the lethal injection they weren't able
to get the uh
the
injected material strong enough for
the people so they're like we can't use
what would you pick b you got electric
chair firing squad or lead objection
firing squad
shoot me take me the [ __ ] out yeah and
this article also says that they are the
person who's on death row is wearing
like a bag over their head so they can't
see when the shot's coming
or the room
in japan i feel like lethal injections
you know they they like shave your head
and you're like in that suit and you're
like facing the wall the double-sided
mirror i love that you're still thinking
about aesthetics right now dude it's not
well yeah yeah shave your head like you
ever seen ted bundy when he went in the
worst in japan
uh in [ __ ] japan you have um
what is it uh they don't tell you when
they're coming
so you are on death row and it just it's
gonna come when it comes and you will
never know it's exactly like you're
going to die you know dude how about
this lethal injection causes severe pain
which yeah dude you're on death row for
a reason so [ __ ] you severe respiratory
distress associated with sensations of
drowning association
majority of cases uh dude i guess just
shoot me
well how about this having a cage
shoot me but don't i don't don't shoot
him with like a weird rifle give me to
do a bazook or something man you don't
think something like just love me to
[ __ ] you up
yeah oh no you should do create a
minefield and let me just walk through
the mic no no no no no no be like squid
game that sucks because it blows your
balls off and yeah but he's but he's
dead yeah i'll be dead it'll be dead
is making like squid games where like
hey if you make across the minefield
there's a thousand mines they're
everywhere if you make crops you get
your freedom at least give me the hope
be like oh this okay
and then i blow up and die but i die
pretty stoked yeah
you're trying
give me a chance yeah you're probably
like that's a big way but if you do
shoot me dude do it with a goddamn
rocket
uh don't do some [ __ ] gun like i need
yeah i got 22. like uh yeah i need
another like firing here
yeah
to death by poison snakes no that takes
hold on
crocodile massive crocodile jump in the
water try to swim across the river
that'd be a miserable day but which one
do you want snakes
crocodile only which one i want for sure
well the snakes aren't going to kill you
for sure snake's going to kill you for
sure but you there's only it takes
forever yes you go crocodile you go ow
you guys there you go all right well
guess we'll see in like a week or so you
die you die you die horribly and for
three hours four hours you just support
go ahead and take the croc it's going to
suck but he's going to roll you you're
going to drown right now i'll take the
snake to drought
crocs it'll bite you pull you in the
water it's fine you drown you know
terrible no no you drown now
blow me up with a rocket dude
what a wild conversation
is quick
rifles
because what happens someone's got a
good shot and they just i've seen what
i've seen uh i hate to say it but i've
seen videos people get standing there
i've seen people get shot with you can't
see anything bro
watch ready watch
just just watch this yeah
i'm no all due respect to anybody who's
gone through this but um oh yeah because
you're listening just say bang watch
that watch out watch how it happens
oh i don't think so yeah that's it
valkyrie you ever seen valkyrie where
they get shot at the end bang no with
with with high caliber rifles do it
again bang
i don't think so yeah i don't know if
they get them right in the heart do it
one more time i'll make it more
realistic because
listen people that are probably shooting
are good shooters
or they're
do it correctional
more time you really don't shoot them
okay
can you shoot me my [ __ ] eye okay
first of all ask me if i want a
blindfold you want a blindfold no
now but you know you have no choice
right now hold on you have a bag over
your head go ahead try to put it on me
that [ __ ] thing off me well then i
just shoot you like this
now watch don't know now say it back
again
love my children
you think you have time for that yeah
yeah you think outside
oh no okay watch right before ready just
say it ready aim ready ready oh my
children
i have two children enjoy that [ __ ]
yeah i'll get you guilty as [ __ ] also
speaking of the people who are going to
shoot you uh the article says they're
actually going to be volunteers from the
correctionals department the corrections
oh so they're not the best shooters
i need navy seals
you need to [ __ ] snipe
you go hey dude here's the thing we're
gonna put you in this field we have our
two
the best marksmen in the world with
sniper rifles yeah if you make it a
hundred yards you're free daddy and i'm
like oh i have hope i'm gonna zigzag i
do my thing that's right that's what you
do i want my heart filled with hope when
i get here you want your heart filled
with hope aorta now when they hit you in
the hip
and it hurts like a [ __ ]
if you're doing zig zags they're gonna
they're gonna hit you and [ __ ]
yourself no no not though
i need you to run these straight pros i
need a i need a straight line they're
gonna catch you right back dude give me
all the odds against me i want a
minefield where it's just a thousand
mines and they're all active and then we
got two snipers up top the chance to be
making are not they're not good good but
i have a small fracture i could make it
there's so many hope in my heart when
you shoot me yeah
yeah you won't hope
that's all if you really want to make
sure you blindfold me and then put me in
the minefield
okay here's another question i've run
the other way would you rather fight
one jaguar
or
five dogs dogs all day dogs all day like
what kind of dogs wait to death to the
dog
what kind of dogs yeah oh five dogs yeah
because you're not winning against
jaguar it'd be tough
300 pounds yeah no no like a panthers
yeah
they're well a leopard a leopard is not
that leopards are a hundred and i think
30 20. isn't the smallest cheetah that's
a big cat well it's a huge cat it's a
[ __ ] huge cat but a leopard is going
to be less worrisome than a jaguar i'll
tell you that i'm less worried about it
[ __ ] look at that 68 pounds look at
that
i mean that's not that big what what
about a cheetah
yes
the cheetah a guy like brandon the
cheetah's not going to attack brennan
now if it's 160 dude
that's a lie in there um 46 oh dude a 46
pound cheat on my snap it's [ __ ] nice
well they're crazy fast and all that but
they're not going to come out i'll take
my chance of a cheetah yeah if they're
like going that field will release three
cheetahs yeah a leopard a leopard might
probably shy from you as well if you're
big but a [ __ ] jaguar we wanted to
come out no you really if you want to
get it done you have to release a tiger
that's fine
would you would you like that yeah i'll
take that you'll take the tiger yeah but
i just wanted to come behind me i'm like
yeah and then you're going to be you're
going to be alive for a while with that
he's going to hold on to you but still i
wanted to go [ __ ] snap that [ __ ]
hard but i wanted to say dude if you
make it 100 yards with this tiger's
starving we have fed him in five days
we're gonna release him if you make it a
hundred yards you're free give me that
dude yeah
well he's gonna run you down
yeah
but at least let me fight you could put
him in your guard there's a chance you
could get your legs around his neck and
hold him there but this claw's dead he's
going to rip you off he's going to rip
you the [ __ ] up and he's going to push
his body out of your you think you can
put him in a rear naked
tough to get his back how do you get
behind him
400 but also just [ __ ] the answer is
absolutely not i know right how lit of a
squid game show would it be if that if
it's like dude all you do is beat this
tiger all you do is evade the snipers
and you're free yeah it's like that that
movie well they would hunt you down
you'd have a chance to get away you have
a chance to get away that's all i'm
saying give me a one percent chance and
i'll take it yeah kill with my heart
soon as you got under that chin they
start you in a river and they sink the
boat and now you have a chance to swim
to the other side and run
yeah run
i'm down for that yeah all right what
else you got jeff all right
sorry a little talk about something i
know
it was a slow news week
and there is a man in the uk getting
very angry with a taco bell worker for
not getting his food out fast enough and
the worker just that is frustrating
people get hungry
he gets body slammed very he's like in
when you order food and they don't
deliver the sauce it's like oh you [ __ ]
yeah yeah you're talking about a
completely different meal right like if
you order chicken nuggets they don't
give you any salt oh it's the most
boring [ __ ] word
you eat it yeah keep it but you eat it
you [ __ ] me yeah the one thing i need
to enjoy my meal you [ __ ] me simply
unfair
his friend's like come on dude
oh he knocked him out oh then his friend
they're drunk
i think hey
the guy did attack him
that guy's dead
oh he's bleeding
what the [ __ ] you doing well you can get
some of this chalupa hands too son
you can tell the workers surprised by
how hard he threw him because both of
his hands this guy this guy's a [ __ ]
he just threw a punch
yeah he goes oh my god
he gave him that nacho bell grande yeah
yeah he gave him the nacho baby he did
he just lose
me first
and it was a fight week so see him throw
see him watch him throw but he throws
yeah right there self defense yeah
there's [ __ ] at us look at this a nice
little fireman oh
boom knocks them out that's tough i'm
talking about floors
oh it's spilled i know nasty there's
nacho cheese all over the place so what
what happened to the dude
slammed the man through his soul
i love descending the man's soul through
the earth's crust based on his reaction
he did throw him going
did you tell me a story about amir khan
and his brother and these skinheads in
england tried to [ __ ] with them and they
he and his brother knocked them both out
i think i think tony might have told me
that story
that's hilarious though that he slammed
that guy's someone said that
this one no go up four that's not
is
i don't feel bad at all you can only
make it worse
what's this one this one
[Music]
that's me
you're probably wondering how i ended up
in this situation
like the start of the movie
you probably want to hang over the
situation is that really him
no
oh god
jim ross and jerry lawler pay a visit to
talk about it what happened here
undertaker fighting back he's fighting
back that round above us folks and i
don't lock him down
oh my god
i fear that guy goes
somebody get out here
oh gosh
so funny all right he's young how old is
patty
27. glad he looks young yeah he does
look young with that haircut
best haircut patty the baddie
oh
this is a quick morgan wallin
i guess his
his album he already beat taylor swift's
record the only way he hasn't beaten his
adele's
this shows you canceled cultures
officially over
yeah longest running ten
second longest running
top ten album on the world war 200 this
century so cool
amazing this is his most recent record
yeah yeah the one that they banned him
from okay he just
oh coming like crazy after that the
community went i'll check out the album
you want to do you want to do what with
them you want to cancel him over oh okay
everybody download his record make it
the most successful record of all time
wit
um speaking of did you listen to that
record tim i bought it i bought that one
and i bought it too yeah i bought it the
day i canceled yeah i gotta shut the
[ __ ] up
30 years
yeah 30 plus years oh man that show was
so real
what are we gonna do without maury i
know but that's a long people were
people were really upset
who's watching
that's the thing people stop stopping
you are not the father people watching
the full show people are watching clips
yeah how many times people are always
watching the cameraman run after the
people oh cause it's the funniest thing
cause the cameraman just [ __ ] books
it that show is so fake
i don't know what network goes on but
like all right man enough's enough
every dude like literally breakdances
when they find out they're not involved
wasn't moria uh click on that
whatever you do don't tell maurice
producers what your biggest fear is it's
just a picture
they keep bringing up the picture i
don't want to be around it i don't
oh my god
i don't know what that is cotton balls
like shaving cream
whatever you do don't tell maury's
producers what your biggest favorite
yeah cotton ball combo phobia please
okay
you
[Applause]
sandy
what is
they should not have canceled this
no oh my god
bring it back amazing let me see more
you said bring out the odds
you scared of peaches
please tell me heat trips
it's so
stupid i'm gonna stay back you say can
we cure sean of his fear of peaches
i wonder how much of this is acting it's
awesome
but it's fantastic that's great though
good actor god remember we found out
jerry springer was fake i was like oh
[ __ ] yuck
did you just fight all the time yeah
yes he was that's who it was he was a
big deal for a while was he from
fairfield
jerry spencer
so the youtuber david dobrik he once had
a video where someone took his tesla and
jumped it off this hill
echo park
i know that so now this guy they just
live right near there i know exactly
where that hill is his boy dirty dom did
this yeah some some part of his team i
guess but so there's this uh asian
youtuber guy that uh has a bunch of like
car fan people would that you know go to
his channel he does all like supercars
and stuff like that he did this tesla
meet up he's in trouble now right i'm
not sure if he's in trouble because he
didn't do it they're looking for whoever
did this well so
well he said that the guy that did the
jump said he wanted to show him that you
know that place where david dobrik did
it and then all of a sudden he just did
this jump and it's one of the most
insane this thing gets crazy yeah it's
like a movie let me see this it's like
back to the future watch on that guy's
youtube channel nobody crashes at the
end it is that's the problem
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
that m3 is pretty lit bro people are
doing anything for [ __ ] content huh
oh my lord damn
it crashed
teslas aren't made to fly sure
yeah he got a lot of trouble
all the airbags went off obviously let's
go
is everyone okay no they're not
everyone is fine
because the car gets out of control and
crashes warning this happened like as if
he's done it a million times before no
practice runs no warning
holy [ __ ] all right well they're telling
us to park here and get out so
[Music]
watch out
i can't believe that's [ __ ] nothing
that is insane that is nuts
yeah that's gonna happen did they not
see the cars at the end of the road
insurance is gonna see that and they're
gonna be like
but the guys who are doing this they
make so much money oh the youtubers make
money but so
then the the news report has said that
the guys are not going to face any
charges like criminal charges other than
just damaging property yeah which is
crazy yeah well how do they get tickets
for reckless driving yeah
flying but it's literally full of tesla
yeah
i think just yeah i still think about
this
black pair yeah i saw this see this pigs
don't [ __ ] around huh let me see this
story that we were talking about at the
top of the hour what the heck it's got
us all talking this evening the black
bear went in for a little pigs go out to
snout
in new milford and it is
fat too pigs don't [ __ ] around dude the
pig said come get something daddy no
they're that bear we're bored of [ __ ]
dude their instincts we're just waiting
to get slaughtered as bacon
oh they're my babies well they're in
shape but i don't know those aren't
those are vietnamese
popular pam yeah
you don't eat those
those are pets
feed those bristle is white as snow
okay not really you look like the people
off 600 pounds
had been recorded not long becoming a
wrestling ring once the bear jumped in
mary the bear said jesus christ fellas
take it easy
helps out too that's when i realized my
pigs can defend themselves i am very
proud of them because hammy the little
one especially he's afraid of his own
shadow
and the way he came charging out when he
thinks she's single castle
get out
come on
come on
balls deep into this [ __ ]
weird filipino pigs
you know weird daddy he's potbelly pigs
they let her have it man
i think maybe you can eat him probably
right oh he could eat any pig i'll eat
him right now i'm hungry
oh they do get fat though yeah oh my god
and they get fat as [ __ ]
that beer was like all right dude [ __ ]
this let's just move on i'll tell you
what i'll eat that as a lion leopard
they love themselves oh any bear that's
not a [ __ ] want to kill them yeah yeah
one of those pigs gonna do that thing oh
he's cute
his nose down super smart dude they look
like they're gonna be soft and i saw
someone walk in a fat ass pig down santa
monica i pulled my car over my i got to
feel your pig yep i've always wanted to
feel a pig no nose
they're crunchy man they're not soft
they're crunchy they can use they use
those pigs
they use them to dig [ __ ] buy one
that's a rooting
i heard that there's no such thing as a
miniature and they say that they're mini
cookies and then they get full size yeah
that's a that's a snout that's
they are
yeah you can put the kids on the back
when they [ __ ] write the males get
tusks yeah cut you up a little bit i i
feel like i've seen a small like regular
pot belly here no i heard they're crazy
celebrities go through a trend where
they had mini pigs for a while like
miley cyrus monkeys yeah celebrities
have gone through anything
[ __ ] you can buy them out here
maybe maybe there's one in socal dude
instead of like how many pigs
oh this is super fun experience with
miniature bass what if i want to take
one home though
what if i tell my kid this is a cat
how big are they
dude here's the not such thing as
there's nothing exactly when they [ __ ]
spruce says i love you guys i can't own
one right now because i live in an
apartment
go to that first one owning a pig oh
that's the whole thing okay i never mind
all right princess zombies you should
own a pig really should i let them get
murdered for their [ __ ] meat to be a
bacon you [ __ ] ain't getting no
pigs no
oh dude if my kid was like dad rather
have a pig than a cat i'd say say less
little dude i enjoy pigs more than cats
they're smart you train them way better
they're you know
now cool would be to have a pig named
bacon
though they bite
pigs yeah okay but cats are [ __ ]
yeah my friend has a pig and they they
have to leave it in the cage like it's a
big pig they have to leave it in the
cage in the house because he'll [ __ ]
everybody who comes in the house up oh
wow yeah they're also feeding bacon
bacon which is a little [ __ ] up in my
hilarious though also hilarious yeah
damn
i wish i had a pig okay you didn't get
pet penguin they slapped though huh they
slap i'll take it penguins not worried
about it they'll slap you like they just
slap there's just no slap back uh
speaking of slapping i'ma slap everybody
at the hollywood improv
this wednesday this wednesday this
wednesday it's brian cowan crystalia
jeff died chappelle lacy myself one show
one night only be our seventh sold-out
show
come get slapped with chappelle's big
black dick that is
who said it was big don't be scared
god damn it okay well i'll be in chicago
this thursday friday saturday though
chicago come get some and then phoenix
arizona stand up live april 14th through
16th and then just announce announce on
my birthday it's very rare i celebrate
things but headlining the moon tower
comedy festival festival in austin texas
april 22nd through the 23rd i'm at the
new cap cities out there two shows
friday two show saturday plus you get
tickets to the moon tower comedy
festival there's a bunch of monster
comics like tim dillon santino bobby lee
sarah silverman myself we're all there
in austin texas april 22-23 so get your
tickets right now but la this wednesday
in chicago this thursday friday saturday
get your tickets at fatkz.com or
thinkboy.com also april 9th is the thick
mudder the tough mudder at 10 30 a.m is
april 9th we have a cowbest fight
companion that night but come run the
15k with your thick friend or you can do
the 5k i'm telling you you don't have to
be in some phenomenal shape right
chappelle like you're fine like most
people they are fine i'm not sure you're
not in great shape but you saw some
people [ __ ] i mean you didn't
even trade for it and you were fine
you've completed it yeah six hours but
you know it was not six or ten years but
how long was it we also have four hours
and 35 minutes and i'll take that uh but
if you sign up now uh get your thick
mutter tea as well from thickboy.com you
get in time before april 9th
thickboy.com miami this is the this is
the month of florida miami florida this
weekend friday saturday sunday miami
improv uh in doral tampa florida two
weeks from then april 15 to 16. then we
got port charlotte florida i come right
back i come right back because i love
plane rides uh vasani theater april 21
through 23. and then i got las vegas
nevada april 28 to 30. wow
utah you're up next april 8th and april
9th uh salt lake city at wise guys uh
march 6 and 7th san diego new comedy
club called mike drops
is that what i said march oh sorry may
67 and then may 12th i'm doing a
one-nighter uh in the hometown at stand
up live
boom all right kids that's it love you
bye